tradition respectée hier soir à limoges
où le quartier des bouchers accueillie
en soirée la très sympathique fête des
petits ventres une manifestation haute
en couleurs en l'honneur de la
gastronomie régionale
inauguration officielle au programme
bouleversé des ménétriers de l'écolo
d'eau barbiche et contraint de rester à
l'intérieur de la chapelle sainte rien
la pelouse qui n'était pas tombé depuis
12 ans ou la frairie de petits ventres
s'est largement rattrapé hier fois
au pied de la madone des clichés la
foule était pourtant étonnamment
nombreuses pour s'aventurer hier soir
rue de la boucherie et se frayer un
chemin dans les rangs serrés les
parapluies il fallait être très
courageux très amoureux des traditions
ou très affamés
d'une telle manoeuvre de la courtine
alors s'arrêter au passage qu'on avait
beaucoup de monde on s'est arrêté pour
voir
les majors après son coup d'arrêt à la
presse que vous avez remarqué qu'on a
pris une étoile depuis l'an dernier on a
une étoile de plus dans la rue de la
boucherie
malgré les intempéries les affaires
semblent avoir été bonne des montagnes
de victuailles de l'après midi il ne
restait dans soirée que quelques
produits rafraîchis et humidifier la
tradition a été respectée
traditionnelle elle aussi la corrida
pédestre précédé par un défilé aux
flambeaux des athlètes en herbe de
limoges 175 courageux ont pris le départ
de la course remportée par michel fleury
du capot voilà ils furent près courageux